foreign
she's singing Christmas music as we
speak literally
she's singing Christmas music in the
other room you can't hear it
you you uh
I just like this you singing Christmas
music
you singing Christmas music
congratulations
[Music]
I think you were
I don't know she said
well she sings Christmas music and she
absolutely does it
to you know I mean did she she probably
didn't even hear it honestly uh Kristen
probably didn't even hear it it's the
night oh well I guess I shouldn't say
that well I guess this comes out the
19th in December when is this going to
come out
I don't know when this will come out
what is this uh let's see
let's see uh I don't know it's coming up
close to Christmas I know that because
we're it's close to Christmas now so
um
oh the 21st this will come out okay
hey uh we're recording so so Kristen
what you doing
yeah
oh she's making a coffee nice
she making a coffee so she is making a
coffee now here's the deal I guarantee
she's gonna look this is a Christmas
this is basically we're doing a
two-parter with Kristen because she
loves Christmas and uh I told you uh
this I've been working too hard and I
thought that you know since we had David
Sullivan on the show we could also have
Kristen on the show and this way I'll be
refreshed and rejuvenated for the new
year and I could start doing
um
just you know obviously I the podcast is
solo
um so yeah so I guess for now we can
just do my dates here as she makes her
coffee but I will be in um San Diego
coming up uh the the weekend of January
uh 7th I will be in Brea California
that's just a club date but come on down
and uh Portland Oregon Seattle
Washington January 20th 21st I'll also
be in Lakeland Florida the 26th Daytona
the 27th and Jacksonville the 28th uh
Florida come get your tickets San
Antonio Texas Sugarland Texas New
Orleans Texas uh Northern Texas New
Orleans Louisiana February 5th uh
Providence Rhode Island the 17th of
February and then New York New York
February 18th two shows at the Beacon
Chicago Illinois Kansas City Missouri
Springfield Missouri look these are all
places I'm going to Austin Minneapolis
Columbus Boise uh chrisley.com get your
tickets and get them and you can get
them for Christmas gifts too if you know
your loved ones or fans or whatever the
hell uh but come on down to the Don't
Push Me Tour I've been having a lot of
good times uh doing the tour I love
being on tour you know I like being on
tour because
um I like being on on the road doing
these shows more than I even used to I
loved doing my stand up but also now
what I love is uh just
doing it uh and also being I'm very
grateful for for everyone and everything
um hey what's up hi hi you look so
pretty
look at you the camera loves you
that's what they say in Hollywood and I
know that because I've been in Hollywood
now my kid I'm kicked out now let's
start with now let's not start with bad
net bad energy right
hell yeah do it
okay well
so we could go
you know what's on there is the Jeremy
renders thing you can do it if you want
to put the headphones on right there
but you don't have to but
I think
hold on okay I'll be right back okay all
right
so she gotta go she gets nervous on
camera she's gonna go throw up and then
she's gonna come back no she's not but
um yeah so we're waiting for Kristen um
and she is going to uh come back in a
little bit my whole thing with uh uh
what I was saying is being on tour as I
love being on tour now and it was a
little bit I mentioned this on my um
my uh
tour Vlogs which is on if you go uh my
other channel not this super cult
Studios which you can like And subscribe
that'd be great we're always trying to
gain followers which I think we're still
stuck at 596 000 don't know what's up
with the algo Rhythm but uh leave a
comment and subscribe and you might not
even be subscribed you might think you
are so subscribe to this super cult
Channel Supercar Studios but um I
described this in my other my crystallia
channel that you can also subscribe to
on my tour Vlogs that uh I am it used to
be like this rock star [ __ ] like I would
go out on stage and I loved it for that
reason but now I love it because it's
just absolutely I just feel very
grateful and that's what I was
describing on it I think my Boston or my
not my Boston one but my uh it might
have been my boss in one of my Denver
one or my uh Cheyenne one uh my tour
Vlog anyway what anyway anyway yeah you
look great the camera loves you
but you got to talk into this
it's one of the main things now
um hello Kristin
hi sweetie hi you have uh this on
backwards did you know that do you want
me to change it it's okay okay cool it
says Calvin but it's backwards I'm sorry
it's very cute
um and uh how are you feeling first of
all but well I asked that because I
caught you singing chestnuts roasting on
an open fire no you weren't singing it
that good obviously that's not true what
I think if we had a competition between
who was a better singer I would win you
are a pretty damn good singer if I'm
going to give you yeah because when you
know how I said like Taking Liberties
and I was leaving and you were saying
Take Me Out to the Ball Game it was
funny though no but I actually thought
wow that actually she did kind of kill
it
[Laughter]
I told that story I have
that's why everyone now people will come
into Taking Liberties because that's
what that's from yeah but you were she
was
like you were doing that kind of stuff
you sing you know what it is you sing
every song like it's a Christmas song
yeah that's what you do that's a good
one right but sure like you'd be like
more human than human
and Dong and that's by Rob Zombie
you know but that's Michael Buble by Rob
Zombie
so
um so so I ask you because I caught you
singing chestnuts roasting on an open
fire well is that that's how that song's
called is that what that song's called
okay wow really good for the audio
people just Shrugged but um
so uh my uh so so you are you love
Christmas and I feel I felt like since
you know we've been talking about I've
been working so [ __ ] hard I've been
trying to do you know oh no no I have
been saying this on the podcast so
that's why I'm trying that's why I had
David Sullivan on and that's why I'm
having you on
um because you guys are so close to me
but also
I need to I need to refresh myself and I
and in January I want to come back with
a bang and do you know because it's a
solo podcast but I figured since it's
Christmas yes and you love Christmas I
do yeah that we would have you on as a
two-parter oh yeah this is a two-part oh
yeah one of them is going to come out uh
like around the 20th 21st oh my gosh do
I have it in me an enemy do I have it oh
do what did you have what in you oh my
gosh Christmas do I have an enemy do you
have what two hours of time oh it
doesn't have to be two hours we're gonna
you know the episodes are a little bit
shorter but um but yeah do you have it
in you you do have it and you could do
it okay so and then also um so one will
come out before Christmas and then one
might come out after Christmas you want
to move over in the taint of the
holidays that's what we call it yeah
okay that's between uh
Christmas and New Year's the taint of
the holidays yeah because it's kind of
just like it's between the grunt it's
the grundle of the holidays oh the
grundle of the holidays that's you could
that could be a song too yeah you're
saying a lot of words I don't like
grundle Jane and Grumble and teen so far
so far that's really good
the grundle outside is frightful and the
Teen is so delightful
that's a beautiful song now you like it
all of a sudden oh the girl what if a
guy lost his mind a lounge singer and
that's what he started singing
immediately my favorite well I'm sorry
oh the grundle outside is frightening
and the tank is sort of lightning the
lightning is
so Merry Christmas Merry Christmas you
love Christmas I'd absolutely do
um what is it about Christmas that's a
good question oh boy
and she's still talking
I mean if you're gonna talk about
someone that talks way too long about
stuff
days that's only you okay only you talk
the most words and cow oh my God you and
Cal say the most words necessary to make
a point like it can be said in three
words instead of saying ice cream he'll
say can I ask you for an ice cream favor
it's so cute I don't know if I told that
on this practice before but he said I
Daddy can I ask you for an ice cream
flavor and bent over like so polite very
cute and I gave him ice cream I'm a
sucker you're a sucker yeah you don't
think you are I think you are a bigger
sucker you were at the airport recently
yeah I went to the bathrooms I was not
with you guys for about two minutes and
I came back and Chris had already bought
him a dinosaur plush from some random
store as we were walking I was like
Christopher you can't just I mean he's
gonna go home with like 45 toys every
time you come from a trip
there's toys I know it's very sweet I
know and so I know the balance of it is
what do I do
I want him to be happy but also I can't
spoil him because he can't get
everything he wants
so what the f what do I do well I think
spoiling is I think we use that word out
of context because I think we think of
spoiling as like
um
like overly loving and really sweet well
there's no such thing yeah yeah but like
we can
we don't spoil him with things do you
think
I don't know I mean he has a lot of toys
he does have a lot of toys but that's
honestly yeah 60 comes from that is true
because he's the first grandkid that is
true and so he's just constantly getting
comes from different people yeah he gets
as many packages in the mail addressed
to him as I do yeah he signs up he has
an Amazon account he goes ooh blocks
and it comes
um
we got him crabs the crap little crabs
and the the he doesn't like when things
make noise no he's the crab dances and
make noise and he says I want it off
he'll do like that and we turn it off
and he doesn't like it on the other day
at preschool he brought um he has this
blue crab that he got from Amazon and it
walks back and forth sideways it's kind
of alarming it actually is kind of scary
yeah it's kind of scary yeah it's
unsettling but it makes it sing some
song and makes a noise and he likes the
crab but doesn't like it when it's on
yes and so we were at his preschool and
his he was holding the crab and his
teacher came over and was like Hey you
know I think today's the day for music I
think we're gonna do some music on out
here and Cal starts crying right and I
was so confused and he was like no we're
gonna keep it off we're gonna keep it up
I'm proud of him for that he thought
that she was talking to like saying that
they were going to turn off turn on the
crab yeah I get that and I'm I'm I'm
proud of him for that because I don't
like music and I was and I was and I was
driving in the car with him today and he
did not ask to turn on the music and he
was just asking and dude he does not
stop talking I know and it's so funny
and it's so cute I'm also part of him
for that he's going to start a podcast
on the super cult channel in a few
months Calvin's gonna have his a podcast
that seems like terrible parenting uh
and he's going to be a star and I'm
going to make sure he's a star and
that's good parenting
so what is it about Christmas that you
like so much
we're just gonna gloss over that whole
thing that you just said well no we
never got to that that was the actual
question maybe you don't know much about
this podcast and I feel like you need to
be caught up but
um we talk about things and as the
tangents hit me we go we go this is an
octopus of a conversation okay and the
nucleus of the conversation is the head
of the octopus but we go on all sorts of
tentacles
so how do you feel about Christmas okay
this is a lot of popping all over
popping like popping from thing to thing
yeah okay I'll try and follow yeah just
well how do you feel about this I
um I saw something on Tick Tock that
really resonated that's weird you saw
something on tick tock
yeah I like Tick Tock wow
um I got dummy viral on Tick Tock do you
oh yeah no I don't even see you on there
well you blocked me maybe
I blocked you all right so anyways and
it was this girl saying that if you had
a good childhood you'd like Christmas oh
you don't
you like Hanukkah no then you had a bad
childhood and I think maybe that's why I
have like the Fondest Memories of
Christmas growing up so yeah you know
what I was thinking is like when I was
we were watching that
Frosty the Snowman thing the claymation
thing where it's always where it's like
hello Frosty you know and it's Mickey
Rooney is playing the guy and [ __ ] and
um
he's playing Santa and and I was
watching it and I was sitting with
Calvin and Calvin loves it and he's
having a great time because we have a
good family and everything is like you
know beautiful you set the Christmas
tree up nice and all that one of the
Christmas trees that we have up nice and
um and I was watching this Frosty or
something and I remember watching it as
a kid and I'm watching this and I'm and
I'm and I'm mixed with emotions like
I've always said that Nostalgia you know
retrospect candy coats everything but I
think if you dig deeper like for me I
was watching this Frosty the Snowman
thing and I was like it was making me
feel good but also very uncomfortable
watching this thing reminding me of how
it used to be when I was a kid and if
you ask me I had a good childhood so I
guess my clinical question is since
you're in therapy and you're trained to
be a therapist sup with that
I think we both know the answer to that
oh dude sup with that I think there's
some under the layer surface oh the
weather outside is frightful and the
childhood was so delightful no matter
what you [ __ ] say I didn't block out
anything everything that isn't loving
isn't everything that is not loving is
also can be considered not
anything that's not nurturing can be
trauma all the way oh Mommy warm
terrible don't you dare say I had a bad
childhood I didn't no no no I know you
didn't but I'm just saying if the
audience is thinking it I called my last
special no pain and it's not because I
block stuff out
as you say you do in our relationship
the guy the guy the concert who's the
rapper that does the face like this
you're black no racist consequent not
consequence racist uh he's wearing it's
like salutations or something conceited
I follow him on Instagram I think I do
the thing that Chris does do they know
about that this
no yeah but well I do it sometimes okay
so anyway I do that this is how I do it
really bad and you hit the microphone
so bad doubly bad so
um yeah and so it's weird though because
like I don't like that feeling and
that's why I don't like to listen to
music as well
just a deeper deeper 100 it's a deeper
dude yeah well
also doesn't like looking at old
pictures of himself oh when we finally
kiss good night oh and that's a man
gonna be warm
we both can't possibly be blocking stuff
it would be too much of a great
coincidence
you have that's what Vietnam
[Laughter]
guys or here's Charlie because they get
so because they might hit the deck but
they are just an idea
I love you
I love you too
um so yeah so dude I'm just you know
it's like
we
so now let's talk about sleep schedules
I mean
you asked me to elaborate on something
you did
you said you had a good childhood if you
said you had a really fond loving memory
of Christmas because you had a good
childhood
and because you heard something on Tick
Tock where a girl said if you had a good
childhood you like Christmas if you had
a bad childhood you like Kwanzaa or
something and I think that's very racist
okay and
um
so yeah
okay we'll go to your next no but I mean
I but I love I do love Christmas I love
Christmas yeah I really do yeah and I
live through it now with Calvin and it's
very sweet yeah and like we were looking
through toy magazines the other day with
him and he was like on that Aunt that
and we were circling some of the things
and that was very I actually felt like I
I actually it was literally the same
feeling that I felt as a kid when I used
to look through those magazines yeah you
felt the same way totally yeah and that
is interesting because
um
I'm not a kid anymore and I but I had
two feelings I had to oh this is so cool
to look at these toys like literally in
the back of my head I'm like maybe I'll
get some
yeah for real
and obviously I've got some stuff that
I'm repressed because I still go back to
being a child no I do too and I may and
I see Gator Golf and I'm like maybe I'd
have fun with that but I know when it
came I wouldn't put it together
um
so yeah Gator golf so Kevin wants Gator
golf Kevin wants robot blocks yep
um and uh anything with a face on it
he's very he loves faces yeah sometimes
we were we were just at lunch and he saw
a cow and he says there's a face on that
cow oh yep yeah he gets alarmed when
there's not a body part on it that is
supposed to be like there was a fish or
something and it had just two eyes and a
mouth and he was like where is the notes
where are the ears fish don't really
have noses you know well you'll have to
tell him that you'll have to be the one
to break the news because I just kind of
bypassed I'll do it in a New Year we're
dealing with a lot with the holidays and
all that yeah
um and uh yeah so so I love Christmas so
that's good it's good that I love
Christmas good that we both love
Christmas yeah
um but also
you know we don't just have a Christian
fan base we also have Jews in the
families and we love Jews and we also
have other people that don't celebrate
either so uh congratulations whatever
religion you are and congratulations
whatever holiday you you celebrate
whether it's Kwanzaa Hanukkah Christmas
or any of the other ones that I have no
idea about and I feel like you guys
sometimes you get sad during the
holidays right there's that seasonal
depression do you
um
during the holidays only because of the
fact that it happens during December
yeah but like the holidays make it
better for yes they over top I agree
with that I agree with that yeah
um
I've always wanted to be a Jew why God
bless you they seem like the ogs of like
all of it like they were like just the
first these are pretty cool yeah and
like they've just like gone through so
much yeah yeah and they still have like
so much money yeah that's cool Jews are
cool Jews are like they're cool yeah
yeah even like when it comes to like
like I think that if you like think of
like the cool race like everyone thinks
like black people like black people are
like yeah you know they're just cool
about themselves but then Jews are like
we we've dealt with what you're dealing
with thousands of years ago and nobody
even really remembers that's how OG we
are you know what I mean yeah and and
and you might be thinking you're cool
but then you're cool and they go like oh
hey you know what I mean yeah I kind of
wish I I it would have been people think
I'm Jewish yeah and I always I'm like
I'm attracted to neurotic energy which
is why we work so well which might be
why I also love you're attracted to
neurotic energy yeah really look at
sweetheart no no I know I'm neurotic a
bit but also like I got that no no no
but also I've got that Swagger that
makes up for it you know what I mean and
you can't argue that oh yeah Larry David
you think Larry David is hot yeah do you
uh-huh oh interesting yeah I have some
issues though well I mean I don't know
this is what I think
I mean this is like so deep it's a
deeper yeah but you'll have to go sit
deeper yeah when I was uh I was a
gymnast growing up and I had a
gymnastics coach named Sam you loved him
he was like my dad um he was amazing and
he was from New York he was Jewish hey
don't flip or something he had family
die in the Holocaust actually holy [ __ ]
and then his dad was on a roof oh he was
Jewish yep his dad was on a roof with
his dad they had escaped from the
Holocaust after the wife and daughter
had died and then his dad fell off the
roof and died so it was just him and
then wait his dad fell off the roof
where in the Holocaust
okay
we got out whoa so Sam's dad was a kid
when he got out of the Holocaust oh God
okay his dad fell off the roof oh okay
and then he met Sam's wife I hope this
is oh No One's Gonna know he met Sam's
sorry Sam's mom and then she died during
childbirth with Sam this is just them
too Christ wait so when was falling off
the roof during the Holocaust after okay
after they got out oh just a freak
accident yeah Jesus wild but he was my
coach he had a accent like you do
he made fun of me
only always and it he was like my dad
and I absolutely loved him and it like
got to the point that I was like am I in
love with him when I was like later but
I think I just was he was just don't
[ __ ] Flip or something man get off
the beam right
and that ain't no tea you get a [ __ ]
four for that
he was the best would he talk like that
a little bit really no he would just be
like talk like that I took a little bit
like that but no it wasn't like that it
was just like what are you [ __ ] doing
right that kind of thing pissed off all
the time well just like he work harder
you know and I'll be like okay yeah
hey you failed all right we're done here
you [ __ ] up right oh okay I got you
and he was also like not a [ __ ] creep
so that was helpful yeah there we go
you look good on camera
um
so what
and I put it in front of you
um all right so you like to wake up at
what time in the morning if you had your
your perfect time to wake up in the
morning
eight
oh my God 30. changing it
why do you ask that because I my [ __ ] is
10 30 10. sweetheart I know who are
we're lying what wait what what do you
mean I'm lying you wake up at 11. no no
no no I might at the earlier I might
well that's not true I don't wake up at
11 at 11 the earliest that's not true
unless you have something to do if you
don't have something to do you're
knocked out of the bed by 11. maybe but
also I'm I'm saying when do you like to
wake up which is I like to wake up at
10.
but I don't want to I like to but I
don't want to
because I want to stay up as late as
possible watching great movies oh I see
okay this is what we're I wish I could
only do like if I could only get five
hours of sleep and be [ __ ] firing on
all syllables I would like to do that
I'd go to bed at you know uh three and
wake up at well I guess I could go to
bed at five then wake up at 10. it's a
point of contention in our relationship
with this oh the weather outside is
frightful let's not get too deep into it
let's keep it on a light no and not
again argumentative
well we spent like the first three
the first three years that we were
together yeah we right we've been
together for six years yeah that's crazy
that is absolutely crazy and I like you
just as much now my darling
that is not the truth
my darling
hi my darling
you don't respect me nearly half as much
I didn't say respect
my darling you liked me so much more in
the first three years it's not even
actually [ __ ] close to the same
amount
do you remember when we were in the car
nope next question the first the first
night that we met
yeah and Mike linochi was in the back I
do and do you remember what I asked you
who's that weird guy no what it's like
are you guys sad oh yeah I do remember
that Comics are sad right are you guys
sad yeah you're like are you guys should
have known then yeah but I I don't think
I was sad but I wasn't accessing all of
my emotions I had my walls up right
because I would not
I didn't like the fact that's a question
I was like well I got to do so many
jokes because we're not getting into any
[ __ ] here right but we were like no
we're not sad we're happy and we were
but well I can't speak for Mike but for
me I was blocking out any sort of
realness yeah because I wasn't a real
person back then
um and what do you think your change
into being a real person like how did
that happen well I'll show you
[Applause]
sorry sorry but it's for the bit so you
moted me so look look I'll show you
I just float away uh yeah what
well since because I'm on I'm never on
the podcast oh God this was a mistake so
maybe we can talk about that stuff what
therapy and stuff well it's just like
the real stuff about you
like oh the weather outside is frightful
you're getting dangerously close to
having my heart beat
it's going so freaking fast I'm gonna
have to take an Alprazolam after this
you're so dumb yeah
um okay can I just ask questions oh my
god dude we might have to cut some out
that's fine okay
um what was it about me that you oh like
knew that I was
um gonna be your wife
you're obviously okay look there's wife
material right you're obviously wife
material but besides that
it was your energy you were just
absolutely the most
even killed person that I've ever met
and I need that I'm nuts okay and you
were just fun from jump and like not
serious about yourself like you didn't
take yourself too seriously that's a big
thing for me when people take [ __ ] too
seriously I take themselves too
seriously and don't go with the joke
that's a huge thing for me yeah your
whole family is so good at just going
with the gym yeah I I it's really hard
for me to deal with
um anything yeah it's hard for me to
deal with emotions and stuff and like um
you know uh but yeah so you're getting
really good at it though thanks or it's
a skill that you are um improving
actively so that's I am trying yeah
um but yeah that's uh you are
um you're just great You're great and
I've I say it on my podcast and
sometimes I honestly say like you're my
angel and I don't actually like the way
I say that because I it you're an angel
and I am lucky enough to be around you
oh baby that's how I like to say it
better than that you're sweet but I say
you're my angel and I don't like the way
that says every time I say that I'm like
I kind of cringe because it's not
I don't think that's right to say but
yeah I'm all right dude wanna hear why I
like you
or why I fell in love with you
I
want you I hate it ew so the tear built
up in my eye went down to my cheek built
up on my chin it got bulbous got too
heavy and too much liquid fell down
caught it bloop and then wanted it back
inside my body one time my Aunt Martha
she used to live in the basement of
Grandpa bam and Grandpa Dottie's house
my dad's mom and dad my grandpa's and my
grandma my grandma and she and she her
husband uh
um cut himself really badly and he was
really old and he said I wish I had the
wherewithal to to put my mouth on the
cut and I would have just drank it and
put the blood all back inside me as a
joke I know but he said that and I
remember as a kid I was like did he
really think that that's how it works
and they were like no he was just
playing but that was how dumb I was as a
kid I was 25. so no but um yeah anyway
wow that was
what we call in the therapy World
deflection no it's one of the tentacles
that we use in this podcast we need to
get back to the head of the octopus got
it okay the head of the octopus starring
crystalia and Kristen Taylor the head of
the octopus but what
so I met you and I had
um been watching I watched your vines in
college wow like probably let's see I
was 25 or six when I met you so when I
was like 22 um
and I remember thinking like I bet I
would like him or like I bet we would
get along you were right
and then I saw you perform and then
um
you were so
I liked you so much more than I had ever
liked anybody that I feel like it it
um jump started my own
like journey to becoming a better person
oh wow yeah because I was like I need to
really get my [ __ ] together if I'm gonna
be like worth him oh gosh yeah and so I
really really did that
[Music]
why is why you seem like that's bad no
it's great I loved you so much I was
like dealing with that kind of actual
connection is what do you mean it's so
hard to actually feel all those emotions
yeah yeah we've had it we've had quite a
journey together
[Music]
you just leave
we have had quite a journey
what's that the lighter stupid dude
holy night not even good pantomime what
you're doing well maybe this can be for
the patreon because I feel like regular
people don't [ __ ] care about any of
this no it's not going to be for the
patreon oh okay well hey let me stop you
right there and it's great but it's not
for the patreon oh okay people like [ __ ]
you know and plus we got to tell them
what they like we do what we do dude
um so that's also why I like you yeah I
know I know
what do we do so let's stop talking
about why you like me it makes me very
uncomfortable I don't want to be so
exposed to everyone
suddenly see more dude I was in you did
plays when you were a kid yeah I did a
Little Shop of Horrors I wish I was uh
the dentist didn't get the role of the
dentist Trent Reynolds got it he was a
senior because I was and I was a
freshman and I wish they did Little Shop
of Horrors when I was a senior and they
didn't instead they did
what do we do when we were when I was a
senior
what the hell did we do when I was a
senior
technical or drink up I think Elvis
that's what I think that's what we did
when I was a senior and I was
uh
uh the pharaoh
um and he was and I was not Joseph you
have Pharaoh energy for sure just like
oppressive why did I do that evil
I'm a pharaoh yeah just like what's a
pharaoh even hmm I kind of make it up in
my own head yeah that's fine I think
that's the best thing to do let me look
at Pharaoh yeah but yeah so we were in
the same first play like our first plays
were the same you weren't you were an
Oedipus no guys goes
um I was Adelaide and you were a man of
many my talents I was I was every part
that was the [ __ ] part that nobody
wanted to do because I was too young and
they wouldn't give me the good parts and
maybe I wasn't good I don't know but um
Pharaoh is a time a ruler in ancient
Egypt
that's that's me I mean I knew that oh I
didn't know that well I I did know that
I did know that but but are they real
yeah okay it wasn't it's not like David
Crockett is David Crocker real no clue
no idea it's not like Joe Biden Joe
Biden real
um so I might the first play I did was
HMS pinafore in eighth grade let me let
me just go through my [ __ ] okay
HMS pinafore and that was the one when
Halal Latif man this [ __ ] story I
okay
so we had to have black shoes because we
were Sailors we could not wear white
shoes the Drama teacher told us
we can't wear white shoes because
Sailors have to have the black shoes
that's what we have to have so everyone
was like okay
Halal one of my friends still keep in
touch with him love the dude Halal Latif
great dude
um had lunch with him maybe you know
eight months ago
uh he
said that he was like I don't have black
shoes and she's like we're gonna have to
get black shoes and he said
I don't know if he said it or if
the Drama teacher said well you you know
if you don't have the money to get black
shoes because I don't want to tell
people to get black shoes you can put
black socks over your whatever color
shoes you have seems unsafe
didn't even think about it I was [ __ ]
14 right so Halal says socks over the
shoes Okay puts black now so now show
time Halal shows up in black socks over
his big ass white shoes it's stretched
out you can still see the white through
the socks they were so stretched out and
hello
um shows up and I'm laughing right not
because he's not gonna spend money on
the black on the black shoes but because
this whole thing now I get how
ridiculous is it it is putting socks on
over your shoes is so [ __ ] dumb
looking and unsafe so we do the the S
the opening number it's opening night
opening number
and Halal is right in front of me during
the whole opening number okay and we're
doing those you know we're always doing
like the Box dancing and then the
[ __ ] hey and then there's a we're
singing a song we're on the [ __ ] bow
of the ship hey hey it's HMS pinafore I
don't even know what the [ __ ] song it is
but um
there is a part where I you know I
remember I'm in this position ah you
know I'm on the left side just going ah
holding the note and a Halal is
below me on one knee uh you know we're
both hitting up oh you know and we're
doing the note and then we have to get
up and go and and walk and oh no we have
to get up and then do a dance and then
and then that's we have to hold this
note right
so Halal stands up and and we all go ah
and he falls back down he falls down
hard because he slips because the socks
are over his shoes okay and Halal was a
bigger dude in eighth grade like
probably the biggest dude in the class
and he's how big are we talking he was a
big dude bigger than anyone I mean we
were we were in [ __ ] eighth grade I
want a pound oh I don't know I don't
know how much I weighed in eighth grade
how much are some away in eighth grade
so he falls and the whole my point is
saying he's bigger is right
because he's also he's not on the stage
we're on this thing that was built
outside of the stage in front of the
stage that covers the orchestra's pit
and it's not like it it the noise
reverberate and so he gets up and and
and we're and we're holding the note and
I'm holding the note and I'm like try
not to laugh and I hear Halal say
whoa
dude no notes came out of me after that
I was just like I guess I'll hold the
position I am
my whole body's shaking I'm crying I'm
crying so hard laughing and halal's just
gonna go ah dude I there was the longest
note I ever tried to hold didn't hold it
but dude I couldn't stop laughing it was
so good
and I gotta bring it up to Halal again
now I'm gonna text him after this dude
um it was so [ __ ] funny and and that
those memories of doing [ __ ] like that
were so fun man theater was the absolute
[ __ ] oh
fear theater was the absolute [ __ ]
theater was the absolute [ __ ]
that's the code word to take me out from
across the building it was so fun I got
the code sentence
fear theater was the absolute [ __ ] oh
the weather
foreign
[Music]
I wonder how much time like if we end up
spending our lives together how much
time I'm doing bits yeah how much time
is just me waiting in the wings while
you're finishing a bit to just like
continue on with my life because this
isn't just like in a podcast setting
this is like my whole life
and you'll because you get pissed off if
I'm not actively participating watching
affirming thank you for saying all that
I appreciate you saying all that I mean
it's got to be months dude I get so
pissed I get pissed off for two look
who reasons sweetheart you get happy for
two reasons you get pissed off together
good all right so here's the deal man
when I'm doing my bits when someone
else's doing their bits you let them do
their bits that's my rule someone doing
their bit if we got a guy who's bit
heavy like for him Anwar he's bit heavy
he's always doing bits he's so funny
he's very funny right one of my buddies
he does bits he goes heavy on the bits
you wait it out you join in sometimes
I'm a professional he's a professional
We join him we have a good time Eric bit
heavy dude Eric Griffin a bit heavy dude
you let him go you join in you're pepper
in if it's his bit you peppered in a
little bit now if you're a civilian if
you're not heavy on the bits and
somebody's doing bits you let them do
bits sweetheart in
in the context of a married couple at
home you doing a bit does not make me a
civilian
[Laughter]
do you use civilian take this
professional comedian
I do
do you civilian take this comedian
theater is [ __ ] amazing
[Music]
like if I don't have my phone I mean
like right now I need to bring like
like little games or something so I I
need to bring little things to do like a
little tic-tac-toe or something that
like while I'm doing bits yeah I don't
even give a [ __ ] if you're laughing or
not honestly I'll still do it yes you do
well no no I want you to laugh but if
you're not laughing I'll still do it
well here's the thing if I laugh
sometimes I laugh oh I'm giving you a
dirty little secret do not even I'm
gonna tell you right now
I've asked you not to do
if you admit what you're going to admit
I have asked you not to do this if it's
what I think it is
I'm going to get upset go ahead
sometimes I laugh
to make the bit be over hello therapist
yes we need a an Emergency session okay
thank you because I know that if I don't
laugh you're going to do it six more
times
and drill that bit into the [ __ ]
ground until I get until I laugh
is that or is that not the truth
[Music]
dude no
no
99.9 of the time I'm laughing for real I
don't know so many [ __ ] bits that's
still that point one percent is still
one out of a thousand dollars
three days
the man of a thousand bits
um I I don't I I don't like that and
that's okay
and I I'm gonna hold it against you for
the rest of our lives is that okay
wow another good answer for the Audio I
will uh I will ask you from now on if
you really laughed at the bitter if you
were doing it no so congratulations hey
shake my hand no
no congratulations that's my hell do you
see now say it in the mic say that's my
hell in the mic I know but say it go
right up to the mic and say it in the
mic you're my hell you see how much
better that sounds I mean not
necessarily the the actual substance of
what you're saying but
Target like this and you're talking like
this sounds so much better
yeah but like you said I'm a civilian
dude
a joke's in your pocket jokes in my
pocket
um so hold on so can you talk about that
while we were watching we were watching
Oprah and the [ __ ] dude and we're
watching Oprah and why men cheat and the
and the dude and the the dude in the
in the being interviewed by Oprah she
was like so why did you why did you
cheat and he was like man I don't know
he was like I like this woman because
she was showing me adoration and she had
jokes in her pocket
she had a joke on her pocket yeah she
had jokes in her pocket dude
um so so we came to the conclusion that
men cheat because they're being affirmed
by women it's not necessarily the sex
they're just like getting adoration yeah
it seems to be the Common Thread yeah I
mean I think there's a bunch of
different reasons why but yeah because
cheating is something that we often you
know talk about talk about in our
relationship yeah we do talk about that
just not
um I think that
[ __ ] we were God damn it I wanted to
do a bit
and then how are you ever gonna come up
with another one there was some bit I
wanted to [ __ ] goddamn do I'm sure
you'll you'll find 10 to make up for it
sweetheart with every bit lost
the 300 movie 300.
with one soldier down we replenished it
with 300 more
um dude I yeah yeah you be careful when
you cut the head off a bit because that
just grows into different bits
you're going to want to cut the head off
a bit um
you're going to kind of you're going to
have a bunch of different bits right
it's like when you kill the leader in
North Korea you never know who's going
to replace it so be careful when you
kill my bits you might be trying to
assassinate it
being junk kill
Jong-il well that's it for YouTube if
you want to catch the rest of the
episode go on over to uh patreon.com
crystallia and you can catch the rest of
the thing with me hearing Kristen we're
doing it in two parts so uh you know
it's either part one or part two right
now but either way go and catch the full
version of part one or part two by going
to patreon.com crystalia also you can
get all the backlog episodes that come
out that have come out uh full in their
entirety and also every month we do an
episode for patreon that is not on
YouTube so check that out too and all
that is just six dollars so going over
to patreon.com crystalia thanks a lot
foreign
[Music]